j'ai ouvert comme je l'aï indiqué hier
aux journalistes une enquête en
flagrance des chefs d'assassinât en
bande organisée en relation avec une
entreprise terroriste
ainsi que pour association de
malfaiteurs terroristes criminels de
nature à commettre des crimes d'atteinte
aux personnes en quête que nous avons
confiée conjointement à la direction
centrale de la police judiciaire
permettant ainsi de mobiliser l'ensemble
des officiers de police judiciaire de
ces directions sur le territoire
français et à la dgs y est donc aussi à
la section antiterroriste de la brigade
criminelle de la pj paris la sous
direction antiterroriste de la dcpj a
été désigné comme service coordinateur
des investigations les investigations
diligentées depuis hier soir me
permettent à ce stade de porter à votre
connaissance les éléments suivants dont
vous comprendrez qu'il soit à ce stade
un peu limité de même que mes propos
puisque l' enquête ne fait que débuter
en année notamment tout juste au recueil
des témoignages pour bien comprendre ce
qui s'est passé sur les différentes
scènes de crime
et aussi parce qu'il importe à ce stade
des opérations de préserver j'insiste
l'impérieuse nécessité de segré de
certaines investigations il ressort des
premiers éléments recueillis témoignages
et exploitation de la vidéosurveillance
que à 21h20 tandis que se déroule le
match de football entre la france et
l'allemagne au stade de france
une première explosion retentit ruiné à
saint denis à hauteur de la porte d du
stade sur place était découvert deux
corps dont l'un est apparu comme étant
celui d'un kamikaze
avec une ceinture explosive composé de
thé atp de piles et d'un détonateur sous
forme de boutons poussoirs ainsi que de
boulons pour contribuer à aggraver
encore le mécanisme et le souffle de
l'explosion
le second en passant a été soufflée par
à 21h25 seconde scène à l'angle de la
rue alibert et de la rue bichat dans le
10ème arrondissement de paris
les personnes qui était attablé au bar
le carillon et au restaurant le p'ti
cambodge ont été victimes de tirs de
fusils d'assaut de type kalachnikov de
la part d'individus
arrivé à bord d'un véhicule noir décrit
par certains témoins comme pouvant être
un véhicule
seat type léon sur place était découvert
une centaine de douilles de différents
calibres notamment de calibre 7 62 mm à
cette heure le bilan sur cette scène de
crime s'établit à 15 personnes décédées
et a dit victime en état d'urgence
absolue
troisième épisode à 21h30
une deuxième explosion a retenti porte h
du stade de france toujours rue rimet à
saint denis sur place était découvert le
corps d'un kamikaze
un second kamikaze donc porteur d'un
dispositif identique donc un gilet
explosif identique à celui du premier
kamikaze de la porte des à 21h32 à
l'angle de la rue fontaine au roi et de
la rue faubourg du temple dans le dans
le 11e arrondissement une nouvelle
fusillade devant le bar à la bonne bière
a entraîné la mort de cinq personnes et
l'évacuation de huit personnes blessées
en urgence absolue selon les premiers
témoignages les auteurs des tirs se
trouvaient à bord d'un véhicule
également de couleur noire et de marque
seat sur place était découvert là encore
une centaine de douilles de différents
calibres et notamment 7 62 mm à 21h36
faux 92 rue de charonne au restaurant la
belle équipe de nouveaux tirs de fusils
d'assaut ont causé la mort de 19
personnes qui étaient attablés en
terrasse de l'établissement causés par
des individus arrivés là encore à bord
d'une seat de couleur noire neuf
personnes se trouvent toujours en état
d'urgence absolue et sur place le corps
était découvert une centaine de douilles
de différents calibres notamment 7,62
aux alentours de 21h40 au 253 boulevard
voltaire dans le 11e arrondissement de
paris à l'intérieur du restaurant le
comptoir voltaire un kamikaze se donner
la mort à son tour et a été trouvé
porteur d'un dispositif explosif
identique aux deux premiers kamikaze du
stade de france
une personne présente dans
l'établissement a été grièvement blessé
et plusieurs autres plus légèrement
à 21h40 un véhicule polo de couleur
noire se stationnent devant vous le
savez la salle de spectacle le bataclan
au 50 boulevard voltaire trois individus
porteurs d'armes de guerre aux sorte ils
vont faire irruption dans un sel et
tirer en rafale
en plein concert pour ensuite prendre en
otage le public qui semble qu'il a été
regroupée devant la fosse devant l'
orchestre
ce qui explique que cela que l'on trouve
le plus de victimes les terroristes lors
des pourparlers tenus brièvement ont
évoqué la syrie et l'irak lors de
l'assaut donné vers zéro heure 20 par la
berri et le raid auquel je veux rendre
spécialement hommage trois terroristes
ont trouvé la mort
le premier tué part entière des forces
de l'ordre l'explosion du dispositif
explosif qu'il portait tandis que les
deux autres chacun ont actionné une
ceinture explosive qu'il portait qu'ils
ont donc actionné au moment de l'assaut
des forces de l'ordre alors je vous
parle on décompte 81 victimes décédées
et de très nombreux blessés
je ne peux à ce stade être plus précis
sur le déroulé exact de ces crimes
terroristes c'est pour ça je vous ai
donné une version minute et par ordre de
2 de temps et de déroulement sans me
prononcer sur le regroupement des
différentes équipes sur laquelle je
reviendrai tout à l'heure je ne peux
donc être à ce stade plus précis sur ces
déroulement quand tu es le déroulement
exact de ces crimes terroristes d'une
violence inouïe compte tenu du nombre de
victimes de la configuration des lieux
et de l'importance des opérations
techniques et médico légal qui vont
devoir être effectué dans les prochains
jours on fait un 21h53 à 400 mètres
environ du stade de france
rue de la cokerie une troisième
explosion est survenue
là aussi le corps d'un kamikaze était
découvert voilà donc le déroulé des
actes terroristes commis hier dans la
soirée à paris et à saint denis
tel qu'il résulte après moins de 24
heures enquête
on peut à ce stade des investigations
dire que très vraisemblablement ce sont
trois équipes de terroriste coordonnée
qui sont à l'origine de cette barbarie
l' enquête va donc s'attacher à
déterminer les auteurs leurs complices
les commanditaires leur parcours et les
financements de ces opérations
je peux d'ores et déjà ce soir vous
indiquer les premières avancées de ses
investigations au regard d'une part des
multiples actes d' enquête réalisée par
l'ensemble des services de police que
j'ai saisie et dont je tiens ici encore
a souligné le plan d'investissement et
le grand professionnalisme et au regard
d'autres part de la coopération
internationale que nous avons engagé
avec nos indispensables interlocuteurs
étrangers dans notre lutte contre le
terrorisme sur les avancées de ces
investigations et notamment
l'identification des terroristes je peux
donner les éléments suivants
à ce stade un terroriste auteurs de la
prise d'otage au bataclan a été
formellement identifié après relevé de
ses empreintes papillaires c'est le
doigt sectionné donc que l'on a
retrouvée il s'agit d'un individu né le
21 novembre 1980 5 à courcouronnes dans
l'essonne
connu de la justice pour des délits de
droit commun puisque son casier
judiciaire porte mention de 8 8
condamnations entre 2004 et 2010 pour
des infractions de droit commun
il s'agit d'un individu qui n'avait
jamais été incarcéré et qui a fait
l'objet en 2010 d'une fiche est sous
pour radicalisation mais qui n'a par
contre jamais été impliqué dans un
dossier de filières ou d'association de
malfaiteurs terroristes
par ailleurs à propos à proximité du
corps du kamikaze qui s'est fait
exploser à 21h20 au stade de france a
été découvert un passeport syrien au nom
d'un individu né en septembre 1990 en
syrie je vous précise que cet individu
n'est pas connu des services de
renseignement français sur la logistique
et le mode opératoire utilisé
sous réserve des investigations et
expertises complémentaires à venir il
apparaît que les sept terroristes ont
tous fait usage d'armes de guerre de
type kalachnikov
il ya des marques différentes dont on
dira pour résumer que ce sont des des
fusils d'assaut de type kalachnikov
calibre 7,62 et surtout d'un dispositif
explosif absolument identiques visant à
faire le maximum de victimes en se
donnant la mort on retrouve en effet sur
chacun des terroristes sur chacun d'eux
un gilet d'explosifs portant du thé atp
donc est un explosif je vous le rappelle
primaire très volatile constitué de
peroxyde d'azoté est un dispositif
constitué de piles les mêmes pile les
mêmes détonateur sous forme de boutons
boutons poussoirs et pour les kamikazes
du stade de france des boulons
s'agissant des véhicules utilisés lors
de la commission de ces attentats les
témoignages ou l'exploitation vidéo
parisienne permettent de cibler un
véhicule seat je voulais dit de couleur
noire et un véhicule paulo lui aussi de
couleur noire immatriculée en belgique
nous savons que ce véhicule a été loué
par un individu de nationalité française
résidente ondes en belgique
cet individu a fait ce matin l'objet
d'un contrôle routier à la frontière
belge
ce matin même à bord d'un autre véhicule
qui n'était donc ni le véhicule c est ni
la polo un troisième véhicule dans
lequel se trouvaient également deux
autres personnes elles aussi résidant
dans la région de bruxelles
je veux souligner à ce point est à ce
stade l'excellence de la qualité et de
l'efficacité de la coopération policière
et judiciaire entre la france la
belgique
nous avons été amenés au niveau du
parquet de paris à saisir dès la nuit
dernière
le parquet fédéral belge donc le parquet
fédéral anti terroristes belges de 4
demande d'entraidé pénale internationale
et en particulier une demande d'entraidé
pénale a visé ce véhicule paulo
retrouver devant le bataclan donc loué
par ce véhicule parce cet individu dont
on trouve la trace dans ce véhicule
contre les prêts à frontières
le parquet fédéral belge et c'est
important a par ailleurs ouvert une
enquête spécifique confiée à un juge
d'instruction terroristes anti
terroriste bruxelles loi et les
autorités judiciaires belges je vous
renvoie en ce sens un communiqué de
presse qui a été diffusé il ya quelques
instants
parfait dérivant de le procureur fédéral
de belgique le parquet fédéral belge
nous a annoncé que l'interpellation des
trois individus qui avaient été
interpellés ce matin l'interpellation
sur laquelle je ne soit pas à ce stade
m'exprimer davantage pour préserver les
opérations de perquisition qui sont en
cours de deux qui sont en train d'être
effectués en belgique j'ajouterai en ce
qui concerne ces trois individus je vous
ai dit qu'il résidait en belgique
j'ajouterai qu'il s'agit d'individus qui
ne sont pas connus des services de
renseignement français sur les
commanditaires l'organisation et le
financement de ces actes terroristes
vous savez que ces états ces attentats
ont été revendiqués ce jour par
différentes vidéos une vidéo un
communiqué écrit puis un montage sonore
pour le compte de dèche donc
l'organisation terroriste état islamique
ce revendications font bien sûr tout
l'objet d'investigations de la part des
services spécialisés
je terminerai en exprimant à nouveau
toute ma compassion aux victimes et à
leurs proches et je profite de votre
présence et à tous et de la couverture
médiatique pour rappeler qu'un
dispositif spécifique est mis en place à
l'intention de tous les membres des
familles de victimes de tous les proches
tous les alliés qui cherchait à avoir
des informations
un numéro de téléphone est mis à la
disposition des citoyens pour toute
information qui concerne les victimes ou
pour des personnes pour lesquelles on
resterait sans nouvelles ce numéro est
le 0 800 40 65 05
je répète 08 140 65 05
je vous remercie de votre attention les
investigations diligentées depuis hier
soir me permettent à ce stade de porter
à votre connaissance les éléments
suivants dont vous comprendrez qu'il
soit à ce stade un peu limité de même
que mes propos puisque l' enquête ne
fait que débuter
en année notamment tout juste au recueil
des témoignages pour bien comprendre ce
qui s'est passé sur les différentes
scènes de crime
et aussi parce qu'il importe à ce stade
des opérations de préserver j'insiste
l'impérieuse nécessité de segré de
certaines investigations il ressort des
premiers éléments recueillis témoignages
et exploitation de la vidéosurveillance
que à 21h20 tandis que se déroule le
match de football entre la france et
l'allemagne au stade de france
une première explosion retentit ruiné à
saint denis à hauteur de la porte d du
stade sur place était découvert deux
corps dont l'un est apparu comme étant
celui d'un kamikaze
avec une ceinture explosive composé de
thé atp de piles et d'un détonateur sous
forme de boutons poussoirs ainsi que de
boulons pour contribuer à aggraver
encore le mécanisme et le souffle de
l'explosion
le second un passant a été soufflée par
à 21h25 la seconde scène à l'angle de la
rue alibert et de la rue bichat dans le
10e arrondissement de paris les
personnes qui était attablé au bar le
carillon et au restaurant le p'ti
cambodge ont été victimes de tirs de
fusils d'assaut de type kalachnikov de
la part d'individus arrivés à bord d'un
véhicule noir décrit par certains
témoins comme pouvant être un véhicule
seat type les eaux sur place était
découvert une centaine de douilles de
différents calibres notamment de calibre
7 62 mm à cette heure le bilan sur cette
scène de crime s'établit à 15 personnes
décédées et a dit victime en état
d'urgence absolue
prochain épisode à 21h30
une deuxième explosion a retenti porte h
du stade de france
toujours rue mais à saint denis sur
place était découvert le corps d'un
kamikaze
un second kamikaze donc porteur d'un
dispositif identique donc un gilet
explosif identique à celui du premier
kamikaze de la porte des à 21h32 à
l'angle de la rue fontaine au roi et de
la rue du faubourg du temple dans le 11e
arrondissement une nouvelle fusillade
devant le bar à
bonne bière a entraîné la mort de cinq
personnes et l'évacuation de huit
personnes blessées en urgence absolue
selon les premiers témoignages les
auteurs des tirs se trouvaient à bord
d'un véhicule également de couleur noire
et de marque seat sur place était
découvert là encore une centaine de
douilles de différents calibres et
notamment 7 62 mm à 21h36 faux 92 rue de
charonne au restaurant la belle itif de
nouveaux tirs de fusils d'assaut ont
causé la mort de 19 personnes qui
étaient attablés en terrasse de
l'établissement causés par des individus
arrivés là encore à bord d'une seat de
couleur noire
neuf personnes se trouvent toujours en
état d'urgence absolue et sur place là
encore était découvert une centaine de
douilles de différents calibres
notamment 7,62 aux alentours de 21h40 au
253 boulevard voltaire dans le 11e
arrondissement de paris à l'intérieur du
restaurant le comptoir voltaire un
kamikaze se donner la mort à son tour et
a été trouvé porteur d'un dispositif
explosif identique aux deux premiers
kamikaze du stade de france
une personne présente dans
l'établissement a été grièvement blessé
et plusieurs autres plus légèrement
à 21h40 un véhicule polo de couleur
noire se stationnent devant vous le
savez la salle de spectacle le bataclan
au 50 boulevard voltaire trois individus
porteurs d'armes de guerre au soft ils
vont faire irruption dans un sel et
tirer en rafale
en plein concert pour ensuite prendre en
otage le public qui semble-t-il a été
regroupée devant la fosse devant
l'orchestré ce qui explique que cela que
l'on trouve le plus de victimes
les terroristes lors des pourparlers
tenus brièvement ont évoqué la syrie et
l'irak lors de l'assaut donné vers 0 h
20 par la berri et le raid auquel je
veux rendre spécialement hommage trois
terroristes ont trouvé la mort le
premier tué par un tiers des forces de
l'ordre l'explosion du dispositif
explosif qu'il portait
tandis que les deux autres chacun ont
actionné une ceinture explosive qu'il
portait qu'ils ont donc actionné au
moment de l'assaut des forces de l'ordre
alors je vous parle on décompte 89
victimes décédées et de très nombreux
blessés
je ne peux à ce stade être plus précis
sur le déroulé exact de ces crimes
terroristes c'est pour ça je vous ai
donné une version minute et par ordre de
2 de temps et de déroulement sans me
prononcer sur le regroupement des
différentes équipes sur lesquelles je
reviendrai tout à l'heure je ne peux
donc être à ce stade plus précis sur ce
déroulement
quand tu es le déroulement exact de ces
crimes terroristes d'une violence inouïe
compte tenu du nombre de victimes de la
configuration des lieux et de
l'importance des opérations techniques
et médico légal qui vont devoir être
effectué dans les prochains jours
enfin à 21h53 à 400 mètres environ du
stade de france
rue de la cokerie une troisième
explosion est survenue
là aussi le corps d'un kamikaze était
découvert voilà donc se dérouler des
actes terroristes commis hier dans la
soirée à paris et à saint denis
tel qu'il résulte après moins de 24
heures dans kate
et qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qui se passe
non